[Music]
we've hosted many celebrations since the
launch of this most relevant of games
we look far and wide to bring you the
most up-to-date and interesting topics
but then there is one subject that we
somehow missed
welcome home my tuber friends every home
is different and love is central to
every one of them
it's a theme that is sure to appear in
our room events i look forward to
virtually visit your dwellings
[Music]
we're playing minecraft hardcore i just
enter the nether if i die
i die hey yeah okay
i [ __ ] this i'm out
that's what a coward would do if they
played minecraft hardcore
i play like real men i have a strategy
in mind
it's an ancient swedish technique this
is how
the old vikings used to do it it's cool
that i actually got this uh
biome this is what the vikings used to
do
they hunt from the trees
year 369 bc if you were walking the
swedish land the woods and you heard
this sound
run run for your life the tree vikings
this is how they that's that what am i
doing
yeah you're gonna die you never expect
the trees yeah
the tree hey hey my tree oh your
baby i'm gonna kill him last
[Laughter]
oh hello child how does dead feel like
i killed your mother another child
run your little fools run
run oh you're sad
well he said damn they're fast jesus
come that yeah
oh what you gonna do about that are you
too fat
hold up hold up i ain't taking no oh god
jesus that's fine this is fine this is
fine hey
guys guys we can talk this out we can
[ __ ] this out
we can [ __ ] this out it's all good i'm
from i'm just a little poor little boy
and i'm lost and i don't yeah yeah they
fell for the old poor lost trick
dumbasses oh they're attacking the
piglets
perfect time to strike from the trees
okay maybe i shouldn't have done that
sorry sorry about that i'm just a poor
little boy
poor little boy oh he shot his friend
can't hit me here
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm too strong i'm too sexy i'm too
deadly yeah yeah
wait a minute i have gold i should trade
with them i forgot about that
oh maybe i don't have to kill them hey
hey hey wait these can i trade with
these guys
hey hey listen hey ohms i got this gold
you like it
all right never mind i should probably
build like a little fortress around
my nether just so i don't mess up i
really
actually don't want to die because if i
die i get killed
i few die die i die twice oh gold
let's set up a perimeter
hey we're cool right oh
it's a piglet
what's that straight from the trees
all right drop shot okay let's never do
that again
what am i getting out of this coral epic
all right i get chopped
god i have to spawn so close to the edge
speaking of bass if you're wondering how
i'm so good at minecraft
it's because i'm wearing base gear guys
the pre-order ends on friday so if you
want to order
uh it's a company i have with two
friends it's all real high quality stuff
not merch it's gaming gear all right
sorry back to minecraft i gotta make a
door did i say one door
three doors what the
what the what hey that looks snazzy i
like it
uh oh yeah let's trade the gold with the
poor people
hey poor don't fight me all right
i come in peace hey poor all right
let's approach the poor people not to
call us they might infect me with poor
hey poor listen up i got gold don't hit
me
i come from this nordic lands to trade
take this
what you have in return
yes do you still want to hit me
it still wants to hit me but i will
trade with you poor man not too close
you can infect me don't throw it down
there you idiot
all right i will make a path for you
before man but don't come near me
do not come near me poor man i will set
the door
do not infect me not too close do not
throw it off the edge
thank you thank you poor man what are
those golden arrows oh yeah
here more gold swedish gold
finest quality don't infect me thank you
thank you kindly
one more
hell yeah now poor man you will you must
meet your
maker i'm sorry you're just too i can't
look
at you you could infect me the risk is
too high
all right let's get this stuff without
dying please so what is this crying
obsidian
he dropped something else and i don't
know what it is and i don't know if it's
worth going down there to get it
this is a real issue i don't want to die
that's what a coward would say
if they play minecraft hardcore i play
minecraft hardcore but like
epic
there we go crisis at diverted what is
this
what is this crap fire charge what can i
do with this
to the surface please very well we're
safe
i think that's enough nether for now i
will return
wait a minute they could just climb into
this this is terrible
never forget i will die in real life
it's a weird joke to make i will die
i die if i die i die all right let's
just leave it at that
ah jeez he's trying to make
impenetration
fortress oh i had more gold
dang it how much does that make i know
someone made a tutorial
on how to do this quicker but i i forgot
all right i forgot sue me
oh perfect we got four more all right i
got a trade i got a trade i'm being
greedy
usually when you can tell you're being
greedy that's a good time to say hey you
know what
it's like gambling you know am i being
greedy right now
nah that's when you keep going i don't
understand why they want to hit me
and trade with me it makes no sense are
there no other piggies
hello i am a little swedish boy
i am lost oh god i i think we should
head back i'm actually scared
oh never mind it's gold
is that one oh there's two no no no no
no no no
the trees i return to the trees
wait a minute they've infiltrated my
fortress here trade
trade me trade me
trade trade me trade
ah shut this friend done
trade i'm just trying to trade
oh they're shooting oh okay might be a
good time to kill them actually
trade
he's really looking at that he's like
here you go now you're dead here
thanks think long and hard buddy
think long and hard
dumbass time to go sorry to make you
gamers nervous
if it's any consolation consultation
whatever it's called i was nervous too
nothing has grown
seriously nothing is it like digimon
where
time doesn't pass when you enter the
other world hello
make your babies grow ain't got time god
damn
all right back to base this is the best
part of minecraft when you got all the
goodies and you go back to your home and
you're like
um
[Music]
how you doing man you're the best
i love you so much look i got so much
stuff
dude we got ourselves a new door don't
escape
don't escape don't escape see he doesn't
escape because he wants to be here
trust me damn it do not don't don't
don't escape don't escape seriously
we got a new door you he loves it he
loves he loves it
uh we got some black stone you lot hey
hey hey
don't kiss in front of the camera first
please please fire chart
spectral arrow and pork chops dude
you you don't you eat meat right
he loves it he loves it he just doesn't
say it but he loves it
okay so i want to get some sand and make
some glass here it's going to be like a
nice contemporary wall however i really
have to pee don't kill me while i'm gone
[Music]
i'm gonna make i understand you're a bit
claustrophobic but i'm gonna make
like a contemporary glass wall here it's
gonna be epic right
don't fly in the lava thank you i'll be
right back
don't worry he's my only friend and i i
want him to be happy all right
i got nothing all right so i gotta get
some
uh glass yeah from the sand
you guys didn't know this you guys know
you can make glass in minecraft
but you didn't know that dumb oh
you see that can you see that are we
gonna should we do it
no no no no no no no no no hey bunny
hey bunny i hear you can jump super high
is that true
is that true little bunny come on bunny
do the jump
do the jump do the jump show us a jump
come on you can do it you can hear it
you can do it you can do it
wow those saw oh god damn it was dark
yeah
[Music]
i keep getting distracted i just need
some sand to make some glass or
he's gonna love it dude my house looks
kind of cool from here oh god
guys i just want sand that's all i want
please don't shoot me i'm playing
hardcore i'm playing hardcore
thank you thank you it works every time
they're so stupid
dude my house is pretty it's gonna look
even better trust me guys this is
nothing
this is nothing are we doing any um
or the cat oh i thought they escaped i
don't care how you're doing for the
record by the way
got me angry that person
hey i'm back hey where you going
a lot of people don't know this as well
but what you can do
instead of having three furnaces you can
write this down if you want i will
charge you you can have four furnaces
and that way you can do it even faster
right
it's impressed shittiest character of
all time
listen
it's not his fault okay not his fault
all right let's make some glass nice
it's gonna look good i know this in my
head i just want to show you guys
there you go nice i'm gonna make some
don't fly out don't fly out
yeah this is nice
he's he's liking this already i can i
can tell
yay nice contemporary
no no no no
come back here come back here right now
there you are come back quick quick
please come back
here
in here hurry
i'm not dying out of you come in
come
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm not dying oh god oh god
oh god all right come here come on
i can hear it i can smell your fear
coming come in
come in come in get in
get in the house oh my god oh my god
come on
yes yes please please yes yes
yes yes yes put it in your off hand yes
oh god hey it's still in my hand it's in
my hand it's still in my hand
[Music]
come here please you're my only friend
and you're all i have in this
get inside
[Music]
is it the door oh my god it was the door
day bad bad
this game stresses me out man where'd he
go
[Music]
i'm gonna cry this is so frustrating
how do i say silently
hey okay
see see
hey hey hey hey stop running wait
follow me i'm trying to make a nice
contemporary house for us
come on get inside please please
please please just stay
okay is there any holes
this is the most annoying playthrough i
apologize
for his misbehavior why do i have to
pick a b as a goddamn pen
no you are not escaping i need to
section him off
there we go now i can build freely nice
nice this is nice it's a it's a great
view i thought for a split second that
that was
um do i have any more of that crimson
stuff
blackstone might look cool i don't know
what it's for
all right house makeover wheel
there you are you like it that's a nice
view i like it
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
thank you for not escaping
i should really put down floor too
should i i know if you place like
this and then you take the axe it looks
like hardwood floor which is kind of
nice
right i'll i'll i'll do that off cam i
don't have to do that now
it's a new day i am so stressed i am a
wreck
dude this is so stressful you ever
played hardcore well try playing
hardcore with a [ __ ] be
yeah okay it's it's an it's it's an
improvement
i want to i want to feed the calories
it's feeding time
it's freaking time it would also good to
have a bed honestly
i think i saw some sheep somewhere i
guess two of them can freak
yeah make babies okay i'm adding another
layer of difficulty because hardcore
mode is too easy for me
if die play through over as well those
these are the new rules
i think that's fair it's too easy
otherwise i said this my entire life
just don't die how hard is hardcore
it's so easy dude this biome sucks all i
have is a goddamn
[Laughter]
so can can i chop this down is anything
gonna
okay let's not tell about that let's not
he doesn't have to know
all right he's fine okay
let's cover that up
mamma mia mamma mia
why mo jang what's wrong with you okay
i think we can do this right let me play
some torches
let's see let's just see what's out
there whoa what is that
nothing awesome isn't there oh yeah
there's villages too
that'd be good to find there's a boat
i'll take it
i find myself tryharding very much
all right let's get it oh wait
yeah the gold please
yo yo we got dynamite
this is a oh nice oh
i just gotta make sure i can find my way
back home i came from here right
oh god i forgot how easy it is to get
lost in my cry i don't know my
coordinates
i'm playing on hardcore for whatever
reason yeah you can see my tower over
there
so wait i am facing
east we need to go west
64 420 that's easy
yeah 64 20. is it cheating to use the
coordinates
must be so sad and lonely right now how
far away is
there we go so it should be down here
okay all right all right i'm out
okay this is a the worst idea of my life
why am i doing this oh what have i done
what is that oh it's a fortress i can't
go there
creepers are like the worst in hardcore
one boom and you're boomed
oh no oh no
oh no no no no no no
no no no no oh
it's over it's over it's over
[Music]
is that a temple maybe i can find
shelter all over the night
bunnies i'm sorry about before that's
just a well
okay now we just need to go this way oh
god
oh god stop
stop don't judge my graphics card by the
way all right it's official i'm never
leaving my base again
okay there's my house we did it
[Applause]
i'm coming i'm coming home
my little bee i want to be
this i need a bed dude oh my god he's
still here thank god i'm sorry yes
oh you're my only light in this darkness
all right
i'm gonna end this episode here next
time we'll find some a
i don't know bender portals yeah
thanks for all the support in this
series so far i really appreciate it
smash like subscribe look at crap
it's proof
yes huge thank you to everyone for
supporting the arcade indiegogo campaign
it was a huge success to say the least
look at this thing it's beautiful
now as a popular demand this thing
now works with pc games top pc games
i'm talking call of duty doom gotta try
this baby on doom
pub g valerian you name it
okay we don't have every game but a ton
of games so the blaster now works with
geforce now which is very cool
it also works with pc it has a ton of
library of android games
it's just a new way to play we're
bringing it to you so
the product is now available at
arcade.games
the website itself is very cool check it
out
honestly but you also get ten dollars
off if you enter the code
pewdiepie to get one of these bad boys
so yeah link is in the description
check it out